jetzt hat er auch abgelassen es ist ein
abgelassen bereich ich stehe stinken
bisschen ich hab müssen dönerfleisch
also hier gammelfleisch gegessen
ich baue auch sagen wir bauen jetzt
einen kleinen weg drumherum
ich mache ich erstmal aus birkenholz
anderem darum herbergen häuser schon
meinem normalen spaceman etwas neues
machen wollte ist lexware die
paralympics quatschen was saarland
behindert findest das ding ist so dass
wir hier in der höhle gehen weil wir
brauchen beide kohle oder du überhaupt
machen jetzt erstmal hier eine kiste und
alle sondern gehe ich eine hülle gut ich
bin du willst so lange keine krieg bakom
ist alles gut weil wenn hier im krieg
kommt aus du das wären gesagt wir machen
gegenseitig nicht mehr unsere häuser
kaputt
natürlich trollen und so ab und zu ist
in ordnung aber auch nicht im überfluss
ich wache kurz ob irgendwelche creeper
kundendaten selbst den weg ja ja ich
mache mich gerade fertig mit ein
bisschen wimperntusche und dann kommt
vielleicht auf geht's ab geht's man ich
hab noch gar keine kiste es mir ein
bisschen voraus in der hinsicht
ich habe die kiste ich packe mir auch
kurz die kiste und dann die beine und
dann bin ich da dann auch aktive stadt
trebbin stand up de nice matin nach ist
auch kompakt ihr dran lies doch mal und
dann können wir schon mal über die
paralympics reden was ich darin nämlich
ansprechen wollte ist das ja auch in
diesem jahr gleich der erste paralympics
athlet auch an den normalen wo ich sie
hat man da der bei den 200 metern damit
gelaufen
gleich 200 meter war das und hat es auch
weil ich ob es bis ins finale aber
zumindest bis ins halbfinale gut
geschafft gut mitgehalten und das sind
einfach die prothesen des einfachen
technischer vorteil gegenüber normalen
bäumen und wenn dann diese info 100
weitergeht normalen beinen nicht bäumen
weil du warst da unten das pass auf dich
ich dachte das aus es war peinlich
vorzeigen dann könnten zu den das ist
jetzt doof das aber in einer kiste
glaube ich hoffe ich doch alba wäre ist
wenn diese entwicklung so weiter geht er
dann den werden sich in 30 jahren die
leute extra ihre beine amputieren um
sich irgendwelche high tech prothesen
heranzumachen wir sind einfach carbon
federn drin
die einfach so viel besser
wirken als menschliches bein und diese
entwicklung nicht besser wirken wirken
wirken ja irgendwie verstehe immer nur
baum
ach so ich manchmal auch so jetzt ist
immer so tanne so und triumphierten beim
sr birke beine baumeln von jsc einer
höhle
ja ich pack nur kurz irgendeines staates
hier in die schönheit aber gerade ganz
ganz viele blöde nachbarn
ich werde jetzt erst mal um holzen das
ist sehr lieb von dir die ganze habe ich
übrigens werden in der nina kraft aber
sollte ich schon längst aufgefallen sein
ja ich auch wo ich es dann je nach dem
mahl das team das den apec wenn ihr mal
fragt was es ist das ist janina kraft
heißt immer in der beschreibung
modifiziertes janina körper ein bisschen
hat geändert und beim alljährlich selina
klavier kann warum nicht wegen meinem
eigenen modifizierten texture pack was
ich übrigens vor dir hatte na ja ich
hab's
ja ich bin nämlich fast tot also bei mir
sehr oft die frage ist aber wann kommt
endlich die shader zurück ja das ist so
eine sache und zwar meinte der sonic
etwa schon vor drei wochen dass die
shader rauskommen an dem tag und dann
kam sie nicht und jetzt kommt er noch
nicht und dann kann ich meine ich wusste
ich natürlich und die mittlerweile kann
ich hab meine eigenen konfigurierten
shader gar nicht updaten weil er es
nicht hinkriegt das heißt es ist quasi
abhängig von der person nämlich ein
bisschen essen aber ich habe schnell als
möglich ja ich möchte aber die tollen
das sind die tollen das ist die mit
wasser so mancher mehr shader ohne
wasser da ist dann auch statt wasser ist
dann eine sahnesoße ich habe wasser voll
cool es ist ein minecraft manchmal du
hast ja glaub ich kein wasser in
minecraft ist das immer so eine soße
oder ich hab immer vanillesoße da drin
du ja genau herr vanillesoße
ich habe gar keine blumen übrigens
wandel blumen schönen gelben blumen mich
wirklich immer ein wandel ich schenk dir
jetzt mal einfach ist du bist also du
bist so unglaublich nett wenn wenn auch
gebe es mehr menschen wie dich hier
reichlich seine meinung zu paralympics
an sich ja das ist einfach dem wir
diesen das ist halt mir ein technik
wettkampf bei den paralympics es ist
jetzt sehr weise bei paralympics
sportarten wie basketball hier
rollstuhlbasketball der letzten zeit
einzig ein vergleichbar aber beim
sprinten
der kommt es an wenn die besseren
prothesen hat der typ der jetzt gewonnen
hat beim 200 oder vier jahre also die
haben mir hat neue prothesen
vor vier jahren war irgendwie zehn
zentimeter kleine jetzt hat er so lange
prothesen ist damit viel schneller und
plötzlich 10 10 wieder größer ist kann
ich ja ich glaube nicht dass das genau
daran liegt ich glaube auch die haben ja
nicht die kompletten beine weg die haben
ja nur die waden weg sag ich mal
die unseren wagen an ich hoffe auch
manche laufen auf dem gleichen lauf
welche mit zwei amputierten bein und mit
einem amputierten bein neuer dass es
natürlich ein fan
ja aber ich meine der also meine kritik
an den paralympics ist nicht direkt ein
paralympics sondern
dein problem da möchte ich gar nicht auf
einen das ist eine sache wenn du dass du
empfindest also ich finde kann man auch
eigentlich so sehen fällt mir gerade auf
aber was ich eigentlich so ein bisschen
traurig finde ist die paralympics an
sich ist eine super idee auch
gleichberechtigung und so ist natürlich
ein wichtiges thema in unserer heutigen
gesellschaft aber ich finde es traurig
dass es so im schatten steht
ich weiß bei der eingangs dingen 82.000
leute voll ausverkauftes stadion und
mehrere millionen vom fernseher aber er
wollte auch nicht sehen von
behindertensportlern ich meine wer von
euch steht mir fünf behinderte sportler
auf die er kenne die erkennt ich kenne
nicht mal zwei aber ich kenne auch
keinen einzigen deutschen olympioniken
oder wie das heißt
fabian hambüchen gibt es gewissheit die
medien müssen die leute aufgreifen
nur wenn mit dem präsent ist oder diesen
diesem dem voi nam auch vergessen habt
ihr eine tischtennis spieler derart dass
timo boll aber ja genau timo boll ja
aber diesen gewichtheber der das team
mit dem foto seiner verstorbenen
freundin aber es ist einfach das wird
von den medien aufgegriffen und so
weiter aber sonst kennt man sie jetzt ja
übrigens dringend essen sonst bin ich
stark an abstellen mit in der höhle
gehen nehmen wir wieder ein thema zu
recht quatschen quatschen thema zu
richten bin ich stark dafür
du hast ja die themensammlung bei dir
wieder auf dem pc aber die in der höhle
die die war fällig wir brauchen eine
neue hülle echt super da wir müssen uns
einen irgendwas suchen eingang oder
wollen uns einmal runter buddeln und
scada davon
wir suchen oder krippe echt essen kommen
sie sehen sie mich ich sehe ich die
reporter wenn sie mich sehen dann können
sie einfach deren ihren führer folgen
dem dem für folgen sie dem führer nicht
falsch verstehen werte zuschauer
der fremdenführer natürlich wären sonst
und laufen einfach rein
wir schneiden es einen so direkten neue
star ja ich hätte zum beispiel wieder
direkten themen aber dass wir quatschen
kann aber deutlich auf eure themen
nehmen
also war das thema der doktorarbeit
ich möchte einmal kurz hoch rampen um
sicherheit zu sein ich das wenig das
thema anguckt dann plötzlich irgendwo
ankommt warte sei jetzt was nehmen man
damals free to play spiele oder pay to
vima weisen kein opfer
was war dann fast tot [ __ ] aber auch
ein kind thema was ich selber ich es mir
selber ausgesucht aber als nicht
ach da hatte ich aber auch mal zum
kommentar bekommt in wiens einfach pech
zwar keine namen zu einblenden aber free
to play oder pay to win also auch ein
jahr an den user der mit der uns das
geschickt hat schickt ja sowohl mir
schon mehrfach zugeschickt ja also was
wir an lois moment ich muss gerade eine
nachricht schreiben aber wirklich kann
er den ball ganz gut quatschen zwar
free-to-play war auf der gamescom auf
jeden fall sehr gut vertreten
du brauchst mir jetzt übrigens nicht
immer umkreisen ist es nicht cool ich
dachte man ja es ist jetzt da und so
also gesetzt finde das free-to-play sich
durchsetzen wird aber nur teilweise
nicht bei großen herstellern deutlich
das ist eben das ea glaube ich und ich
hab's ubisoft auch war
die haben sich jetzt ihre firmenpolitik
das sind ja alles aktien hier
aktiengesellschaften das heißt aktionäre
müssen jetzt wieder ganz weit ausholende
ob er ganz grob die leute kaufen sich
leute kaufen sich aktien und dann gehört
den mini teil vom unternehmen bedeuten
sich viele aktien wird in großer teil
soll das heißt es unternehmen muss immer
das machen was die aktionäre wollen und
auf diesen aktionärsversammlung die ein-
oder zweimal im jahr stattfinden hat
dann hier noch ein anderer großer
hersteller ich glaube was activision war
also die hersteller die herrschaft von
publisher von dort ist eben electronic
arts ea ist genauso großer bin habe ich
ich glaube nicht dass activision das war
das hat man durch vergangene eignet sich
übrigens auf jeden fall und es waren ja
bis jetzt jetzt ich meine die haben die
ganzen serien wie fischer oder soweit
das ist ja komplette gegenteil von von
free to play sind ja vollpreistitel
alles und die wollen sicherheit komplett
auf free-to-play konzentrieren weil die
raubkopierer rate also raubkopierer ist
ein scheiß begriff den man nicht
verwenden sollte schwarzkopien sind
geeigneter begriff der wo bist du
ich bin da nicht weit weg von dir ich
wollte eine höhle reihen
wenn ich traurig bin schon längst wieder
zurückgelaufen das jetzt blöd
sie ist irgendwas das durch eine höhle
flat bist du da rein
ich sehe ich noch nach links läuft nach
links links links letztes jahr bestätigt
gut ich habe mein krieg hinter mir ja du
den heute dann von versen und k
ich kann nicht mehr sprechen ich habe um
die hersteller habe ich dir gegeben
ach so dass also bei mir ist denn nicht
hinter dir jetzt hat er auch abgelassen
es ist ein abgelassene reich ich stehe
stinken bisschen ich habe müssen
dönerfleisch also hier gammelfleisch
gegessen
läuft etwa die klubs aber hier war mir
zu dem thema stehen geblieben nicht dass
wir sie uns wünschen dass interplay her
genau und die haben sich wirklich dann
jetzt konzentrieren
ja jetzt kein spaß sondern auch auf der
gamescom ist denn auch alles da wieder
presse mit gesagt ja wir machen jetzt
ganze free to play und ich sehe das als
falschen sich die bisherigen free to
play spiele ansieht wann das alles flops
teil besser ja es gibt nennt mir ein
also league of legends ja oder ja wow ja
okay das kostet wesentlich feature play
soll ist eigentlich das einzige league
of legends das einzige gut erklärt
natürlich wieder leute in den
kommentaren ankommen aber das spiel was
ich hier spiele software player das ist
ja ganz toll aber es gibt keine spieler
die da irgendwie somit free-to-play
herankommen werden an die verkaufszahlen
von mw3 oder fifa ich weiß wieder werden
als auch sagen mw3 war klar es wird
nicht gekauft das muss ja nur einfach
gespielt werden das wird mit sicherheit
rankommen ja meine von den
verkaufszahlen ich meine nicht download
zahlen sondern auch wirklich die leute
die sich das nicht runterladen sondern
auch weiter geld dafür ausgeben weil das
ist ja wirklich der hinter dem einst die
leute die auch wirklich geld dafür wird
ja genau die leute kommen wir auch recht
zur nächsten punkt warum ist ihr rotes
licht und warum liegt die stroh das war
ich nicht fragen aber alarm
alar ehemaliger alarm
warum suchen schlechter porno synchrony
weil das eben wir kommen damit zum punkt
vom thema auch free to play to win
und zwar dass man einfach dann dafür
bezahlt und dann irgendwelche sachen
bekommt die leute die nicht bezahlen
nicht bekommen und das dann ist man
quasi schon wenn man das spiel mag wie
ist man dazu gezwungen zu bezahlen und
das ding ist dass die leute die halt
geld dafür bezahlen gewinnen und das ist
doch nicht der reiz ich bin ich meine
das macht aber spaß an der steige zahle
und dann denke ich kann sie gleich sagen
warum es doch spaß mal aber vom aus
meiner seien erst mal so das macht doch
keinen spaß wenn ich weiß gold konnten
fünf euro das super geile schwert damit
kann ich mit jedem mit ins sofort mit
areal aber arbeitet komplett bezahlen
sind wahrscheinlich weiß die an die
leute die nicht bezahlen sind total
schlecht aber das ist ja gerade der sinn
der sache was ea will dass jeder dann
wirklich bezahlt dass leute die das
wirtschaftlich gesehen aber ich mache
keinen spaß
dass leute denken hey das spiel is geil
aber ich krieg irgendwie immer nur auf
die fresse aber gegen die ganzen npcs
und vom computer gesteuerte leute
gewinne ich immer das heißt gegen die
anderen könnte dies vielleicht auch
aufnehmen aber derzeit schwer das kostet
fünf euro
das kaufe ich mir doch auch mal dann
kommt er natürlich weiter das ist
natürlich gut dass es fehlt das
psychologisch anders gesehen schon aber
das muss halt jeder selbst für sich
sehen man hat eigentlich ist die idee an
sich ganz interessant dass man quasi
erst mal so bleiben gucken aber man kann
es genauso mit demos machen und dann in
einheitspreis verlangen von 60 euro
so macht es nämlich ea mit fifa die
ganze zeit seit mehreren jahren da
veröffentlichen sie immer einen monat
vorher eine demo wo man nur ein spiel
spielen kann in einer bestimmten zeit
kann man gucken gefällt mir dass oder
nicht und dann kann man sich nachher
kaufen für 60 euro
matthäus ist aber schon lange vor viel
farbe auf das dings von also das
wirtschaftlich klar nun die aktionäre
den auf der versammlung beifall
geklatscht haben
da kommt eine anja neues konzept damit
vor dem wir ganz viel geld udo udo denkt
sich ich bin so schlecht dem spieler da
kann sich für fünf euro wert kaufen und
der spielt er machte der verdient doch
genug geld der gibt die fünf euro aus
und dann aktionäre sagen hey cool wie
verdient doch wieder geld weil das kann
man ja gar nicht dieses fünf euro
schwert kann man gar nicht auf mord
totschlag kopieren und alle sind sie
sagen ja aber der spieler an sich denn
unser spielertypus also wir sind die
leute jetzt hier wird für mich die sich
eigentlich auch schon 50 euro spiel
kaufen oder 30 euro spielt man sich
ordentlich weil 50 euro für mich auch
schon über teufels und vollpreistitel
und dann das spiel einfach durch spielen
und nicht überall dauern wieder führen
schwert oder führen dass das auto oder
sowas
ich bin allgemein ich mal etwas bezahlen
nochmal was bezahlen muss tatsächlich so
dass schnee mag ich nicht ist nicht wahr
dass das da wird uns eure meinung auf
jeden fall interessieren den kommentaren
die fans gleich auch schon wieder vorbei
und mir fällt auf ich habe keine
spitzhacke mehr das heißt ich habe auch
kein heu dritte oder vierte folge war es
die dritte jetzt kommt gleich die vier
taste zufällig ein holz oder so rein gar
nichts leider kann heute wäre ich mir
beginne jetzt auch um den rückweg du ich
habe auch erst mal genug sein aber ich
sehe noch kohle und eisen und alles
mögliche dann nimmst doch schnell mit
oder kann ich habe mir kein mit
kleinholz für irgendwie was zu machen so
ist eine oberfläche europa schreibt noch
aber noch ich hab holstein spitzhacke
die ganze haben und wo bis oben ich
komme jetzt dann wieder runter geht ganz
einfach und schnell und unkompliziert
dies in meinen namen jetzt hast du denn
gar keine fackeln weil es bei hier
unglaublich dunkeln bei mir ich hab
fackeln du kannst auch gerne mit hin zu
mir ich hab mal ein bisschen besser
ausleuchten
ich habe meinen weg habe ich dann
komplett ausgeleuchtet du so bist du ich
habe einen breiten ist hier relativ hoch
ich will ja gar nicht auch ich sehe dich
schon bleibt man da stehen einfach ich
sehe dich ziehst du mein name ist
redlich um vielleicht man sich
vielleicht ein bisserl okay du bist
jetzt unter mir ungefähr
ja ich fühle mich ein bisschen runter
wartenberg stehen